[Music]
jackie joins us in san antonio jackie
welcome to the ramsay show
hey um thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can i help
hey um i have a question we are working
on our debt snowball we have about 23
000 left on our regular snowball and
then i kind of have our whatever i have
in collection separate
um to pay once we're done with our
regular snowball
and i've gotten served and i have a
judgment against me for one of the
collections and my question is should i
pay that off first
and then continue working on our
snowball or should i just let them hang
out until i get to them
what kind of debt is this in collections
it's a credit card okay how much debt
um the balance on the account is 50 200
and i've called them before to try and
settle and the lowest they would offer
me was 3 600 and i just didn't have that
at the time i could probably settle for
that amount now
um but i would obviously want to
negotiate a little bit lower if i could
i would uh yeah i mean you can try to
negotiate lower and if they give you a
lower number i would just pay that
settlement in full and then continue on
with the debt snowball i don't like that
there's a judgment in my life i don't
like them yeah this is i mean i feel
anxiety and it's not even my debt and
collection
yeah and the rest of the debt snowball
what's the other kind of debt
um all credit cards pretty much in a car
okay we've been on a spending spree this
has been fun well a little bit it's it's
been a journey that's for sure but now
there's a judgment so it got a lot less
fun
yeah you got to pay the piper
okay so yeah i would i would go ahead
and uh negotiate with them if they can
but really i mean it's the debt is the
debt and if they're unwilling to budge
uh i wouldn't push it too much further i
want to i want to get this out of my
life do you have a 3600 on hand
um
kind of yes
we refinanced our house so i have a
refund on our escrow account that's
coming back so i will have that money
okay well make sure your four walls are
taken care of it sounds like you're
doing okay in that category
right you got food on the table
utilities are being paid all that stuff
yes okay yeah i would get this
collections mess cleaned up because of
the judgment involved here and it's a
little bit of a fire and i want to put
this fire out and then continue on with
my life with the traditional debt
snowball
awesome thank you thanks so much for the
call appreciate it